sometimes it feels like every other
movie and theatres and all superheroes
but how did we get here for the answer
we need to go all the way back to the
40s the first appearance of most modern
superheroes were serialized adventures
serials are so old that even five years
before Casablanca audiences were
blasting off with the first comic movie
Flash Gordon
in 1936 this was followed in short order
by serials for Captain Marvel Superman
Batman the shadow Zorro and the Phantom
but as serials were phased out of the
movie-going experience Studios seemed to
lose interest in costume crime-fighting
the wave of 60s and 70s superhero TV
shows didn't seem to translate well into
an interest in movies with the notable
exception of 1966 is Batman the movie
which was in fact filmed for television
and recut for theatrical release and
then nothing 12 years without comics
represented in film then in 1977 Star
Wars broke all previous box-office
records and changed the way Studios look
at movies executives went looking for
the next blockbuster in the 1940 serials
that had inspired George Lucas's vision
and what they found was Superman Richard
Donner's 1978 epic spawned plenty of
sequels and imitators both unfortunately
of rapidly diminishing quality
in 1989 Tim Burton's Batman redefined
what comic-book movies could be funny
exciting and darkly original Batman 89
showed Studios how to do a superhero
movie everybody needed to see much like
1978 Superman Batman created a wave of
sequels and interest in superhero
properties new and old but as with
Superman not all of these films were
well-received or even competently made
by the end of the decade pickings were
fairly slim 1996 is Batman and Robin had
killed the bat franchise and the
studio's had started to experiment with
relatively unknown properties like steel
spawn and blade in the 2000s the market
for comic movies exploded again driven
by movies like x-men and Sam Raimi's
spider-man action movies the standard
big movie experience for the last two
decades were replaced by films inspired
by comics the comic boom of the new
millennium started colorful then grew
darker inspired by the success of
Christopher Nolan's Batman films then
expanded its scope copying the extended
universe model created by marvel
all-in-all comic movies made since 2000
have grossed more than 20 billion
dollars in theaters internationally
which helps explain why most major
studios have the next 10 years of comic
film releases already planned what's
your favorite comic movie which comics
would you like to see in movie form
comment below and let us know how you
feel and be sure to click here to watch
our in-depth analysis of the history of
comic movies since 2000